i protect all of my passwords accounts
and devices using aura i get instant
alerts about threats like if my email or
password are found on the dark web so i
can fix the problem fast try aura free
for two weeks using my link below
well a criminal investigation has been
opened into florida republican governor
ron desantis's stunt wherein he paid to
fly 50 migrants from texas to the
massachusetts island of martha's
vineyard and wow how quickly this has
all developed think back to the
beginning when we first found out that
ron desantis remember ron desantis
governor of florida
paid
millions of dollars in taxpayer money to
fly migrants from texas to martha's
vineyard we thought well
it's a very stupid and brazen and
tasteless political stunt but that's as
far as it goes at least potentially
we then learned oh
you know the migrants were lied to
they were promised things they were
promised that they were being taken to
boston for expedited something or other
and help getting jobs and whatever else
the case may be that's not true you know
that's sort of like fraudulent human
trafficking maybe there's something
criminal there
and yesterday on the show i had three or
four different commentaries from lawyers
saying yeah
this actually does seem like it's a
crime these were folks that were
trafficked illegally by ron desantis and
those deputized by ron desantis for this
stunt so that where we left it yesterday
was
what next is there an investigation what
happens next
and now indeed there is a criminal
investigation that has been opened
the miami herald reporting texas sheriff
will investigate florida flying
venezuelan migrants to martha's vineyard
we have a video in fact of bexar county
sheriff javier salazar
who explained what his investigation is
going to be and remember
desantis is in florida but he decided to
get involved with texas and that's why
the sheriff
is from texas the location the source
where these migrants came from
we are opening up a case uh with an
investigation with regard to the
suspected
uh
activities involving the
48 migrants from venezuela that as we
understand it at this point the facts of
the case at this point
are that on wednesday september 14th uh
here in bexar county in the city of san
antonio
uh our understanding is that a
venezuelan migrant was paid what we
would call a bird dog fee to recruit
approximately 50 migrants from the area
around a migrant resource center on san
pedro uh here in san antonio you know
they talk about democrats as the
criminals
this is this is just straight up
criminality if it's as alleged
uh as we understand it 48 migrants were
uh lured i will use the word lord under
false pretenses uh on into into staying
at a hotel
for a couple of days uh they were taken
by airplane at a certain point they were
shuttled to an airplane
uh where they were flown to florida and
then eventually flown to martha's
vineyard again under false pretenses is
the the information that we have that
they were promised work they were
promised the solution to several of
their problems
they were taken to
martha's vineyard from what from what we
can gather
for nothing for a little more than a
photo op video up
and then they were unceremoniously
stranded in martha's vineyard
what infuriates me the most about this
case is that here we have 48 people that
are already on on hard times
right they are here legally in our
country at that point they have every
right to be where they are now remember
that that's this is an important detail
the right has been just using the
blanket term
illegal immigrants
these are folks as as i understand it
and as it seems like the sheriff
understands it as well and we'll see if
he even explains this
who were in the process of having asylum
asylum claims reviewed
meaning that at this particular point in
time these were not individuals subject
to deportation for illegal immigration
this is an important detail and i
believe that they were preyed upon
somebody came from out of state preyed
upon these people
um
lured them with promises of of a better
life which is what they were absolutely
looking for and with the knowledge that
they were going to cling to whatever
hope they could they could be offered
for a better life
uh to just be uh exploited and uh
hoodwinked into making this trip to
florida and then onward to martha's
vineyard for what i believe to be
nothing more than political posturing to
make a point well look
we all know that during a political
campaign things can get
nasty things can get out of hand
so the point here is criminal
investigation is starting and we're
going to follow it very closely now this
may not be the only criminal
investigation into ron desantis stunt
and i say uh
investigate criminally in all
jurisdictions where this stunt um
extended its tentacles business insider
reporting a massachusetts state lawmaker
representing martha's vineyard is
seeking a federal trafficking probe
human trafficking probe after desantis
relocated migrants to the island this
article again from business insider says
state representative dylan fernandez a
democrat representing martha's vineyard
called on the justice department to
launch a probe
after desantis chartered two planes for
more than 600 thousand dollars in
taxpayer dollars to transport 50
migrants from texas to the island last
wednesday multiple criminal
investigations being requested and that
is exactly what needs to happen now the
truth
again i i hate to have to be
so apparently cynical
but much like i've said if you're
waiting for the trump in an orange
jumpsuit behind bars moment
um
you're gonna be waiting a very long time
i don't think there is any chance that
desantis goes to prison for what he did
particularly when he's the governor and
while the buck stops with him the actual
acts were carried out and and
logistically organized by people
under desantis i i get it guys the buck
stops with him and and that's ultimately
where it where it should stop
if we're waiting around for desantis to
end up in prison i think we're sort of
putting the target a bit too high
however
is it possible that this stun
and all of the negative publicity that's
coming with it i mean there's positive
publicity as well from the right
although some on the right aren't
pleased but will the negative publicity
that's coming for it
from it
maybe hurt desantis in his imminent
re-election campaign in florida where as
we talked about on the bonus show
yesterday desantis is currently winning
by about an average of four or five
against charlie crist maybe i think
that's that's the optimistic scenario
not that desantis ends up in prison uh
by the way
if you did what was done
except it was with young girls to lure
them into prostitution
you damn well could end up in prison but
this is different this is the republican
governor of florida but be that as it is
be that as it may uh whichever is your
preference um i think the the best case
scenario here is this hurts desantis's
re-election campaign and he's as of
right now looking like he's going to
sail to that re-election
at least there's a criminal
investigation we'll leave it there for
today
this is such a funny moment from queen
elizabeth's uh funeral yesterday i had
no interest in the queen's funeral i
didn't watch any of the queen's funeral
i just don't think it's not interesting
to me i don't think it's really
interesting to my audience very few
people even emailed me you know we get
hundreds and hundreds of emails a day
and
barely any about the queen's funeral no
requests to cover it couple of emails
from people saying the monarchy is
outdated with which i would agree but
this is just a really really funny
moment so
global media covered the queen's funeral
and this included australian media and
there is an unbelievable
dare i say kafka-esque moment
where the new prime minister of the uk
arrives liz truss
and the australian media covering it
sort of says we don't really know who's
showing up now we're kind of getting to
the dregs i think they use the pointy
end or something like that
and then they're told apparently in in
like an earpiece that that's actually
the british prime minister liz truss
and it's just an unbelievable moment
check this out instantly going viral and
and i i just love it
no hard to identify maybe
minor royals members of the
i can't identify them at this point yeah
these could be minor royals
unfortunately
they look like they could will be local
dignitaries it's hard to see these are
just locals of some kind looking at the
back of their heads but i think we are
now getting to the pointy end as they
say of the
was
i'm just told that was trust the new
prime minister in the distance that we
could see
and i love the little add-on of in the
distance like she's so far away from the
shot like way way way over there it
could have been anybody it just happens
to be listeners it was stressed someone
had to tell us that that's who it was
um
it is truly an unbelievable moment and
you know for there's no big point here
other than how funny this is
other than
this is all such a charade it is all
just such a charade and of course
everybody should get to
have whatever
um
service and funeral and whatever that
they want and the family wants and
everything we're not trying to deny that
to anybody
but the entire pomp and circumstance
around this funeral has just been
something else and this just sort of the
cherry on top minor royals of some kind
it's the dregs it's the bottom of the
barrel oh it's the british prime
minister very far away out in the
distance all right if you um if you're
curious about that clip you can you'll
find it on our twitter at david pakman
show you can also follow me on twitter
at deepakman we're going to take a quick
break we have a lot of very important
things coming up on today's program
imagine this scenario you try logging
into your email account to see that your
password was changed a few hours ago
except you didn't do it and then you get
notifications of activity from your bank
and from your credit cards but you
didn't do any of it that is what
identity theft is like it can happen
very quickly and if you don't act fast
it can get worse we've dealt with this
at the david pakman show you can find
videos about it and that's why i protect
myself now using aura our sponsor aura
is identity theft protection fraud
monitoring password management and an
antivirus all in one easy to use app
aura will monitor the dark web for your
emails passwords and social security
numbers and will send you alerts quickly
to your phone and email or also gives
you near real-time alerts on suspicious
credit inquiries like if someone was
opening a loan or a credit card in your
name and if you sign up at aura.com
pacman you will get a free two-week
trial which you can use to see if your
login credentials have been leaked
online
i would want to know that right away use
the link below all right let's discuss
some of the goings-on of the last 24
hours as joe biden has continued to
not really make a big deal out of
himself one way or the other but just
kind of like be a very
calm presence as president of the united
states doing some things that i like and
then
certainly there are things i would like
joe biden to do that he has not done but
it's just sort of been very normal
feeling the failed former president
donald trump has been doing interview
after appearance after declaration
showing truly how sick he is at this
point in time and the first example of
this that i want to look at is an
interview that donald trump gave
yesterday to newsmax
these interviews are
these would make north korean news
anchors blush these would make russian
propagandists say oh no that this is
even too much for me
here is a statement trump is completely
scrambled his brain is completely
scrambled where in the same 50 seconds
he says that he built the wall
but that he would have built the wall if
he had only had three more weeks and
also quite telling
that increasingly trump is not doing
interviews with fox news he's doing them
with newsmax and that's all part of the
sort of downfall of trump and we'll talk
more about the data behind that claim in
a moment mr president you know another
issue that the biden administration is
really
completely messed up is the border and
it's just totally messed up guys now
what you have is governor
ron desantis
is
taking offensive action he's taking some
of the immigrants and putting them in
martha's vineyard
really an incredibly important thing
that desantis did
i think that the border is such a
disappointment because we had the safest
border we had the best border in the
history of our country
we built the wall and then i built
additions to the wall which could have
been finished in
three weeks i built he built the wall
now remember the wall was defined as a
wall across the entire border he says we
built the wall
and then we could have finished it
within three weeks wait so did you build
it or did you not the majority of it ah
and everything we said we were going to
get done and then they came to me and
they wanted to know we could do an extra
150 to 200 miles yeah they came to me
with tears in their eyes and they said
sir we need another 100 miles no listen
um the promise that trump made was a
wall across the entire southern border
by the end of his first term uh by
different accounts something like 90 to
100 and something miles were added and
of course it's a wall that could be
defeated with about a hundred dollars
worth of parts from a home depot or a
hardware store donald trump then said
that the video of the search warrant
being executed at mar-a-lago looks like
a military coup which is interesting
language from the guy who tried to
execute a coup president we keep hearing
about
video recordings at mar-a-lago that
would have captured
the raid have you had conversations
about releasing that footage right yes
we have and
they would rather have me not do it
because of the safety of the fbi agents
that swarmed the place right
trump's really concerned with keeping
the fbi agents safe i don't think they
wanted to swarm it if you want to know
the truth i have a great relationship
with
people in the in in the fbi but they
didn't we are very precise and and you
know it's not a pretty picture either
it looks like uh
a military coup
it's not a pretty picture you know they
didn't want they wanted to uh
for the safety of the people that are on
the footage is very clear
and for the safety of the people that
are in the footage they would
they've asked us not to uh
not to put it out
you know it's very interesting
that
reality
doesn't have any bearing anymore to the
extent that it ever did right anymore
um when these right-wingers talk about
things in the real world right for a
very long time the january 6 riot coup
insurrection attempt call it what you
want
it was peaceful and it was beautiful and
it was a great thing
and then all of a sudden it was well no
it was violent but it was antifa
and then it was well no it's a it
doesn't really matter it's just whatever
they can say at the time and now
something that was very peaceful the fbi
shows up with a signed search warrant
fbi director signed off on it attorney
general merrick garland signed off on it
judge signed off on that now is a
violent military coup and trump kind of
continued playing this up when he talked
about how violated melania felt when the
fbi ruffled through her dresses
and maybe other things of hers as well i
i'm uh wondering how melania felt about
the raid yeah
by the way a really hard-hitting
question from i believe this is rick
grinnell who's like a former trump
staffer doing the interview i guess he
works for newsmax now who knows
really incisive journey how did melania
feel about what happened
well
she felt
very violated i mean this is a terrible
thing
anyway trump would know about women
feeling violated right to her closet
they go through her dresses and who
knows what else
and uh it wasn't left away
her dresses by the way they didn't go
through her scarves
they didn't go through her blouses
but those dresses they were right up in
there found it okay you know they didn't
exactly i didn't i didn't walk into mine
and say oh this is exactly so nice the
way they put it back
uh i think it's a disgrace to the thing
like this could happen yeah and again we
didn't do anything wrong i didn't do
anything wrong
there was nothing done wrong you take a
look at the
presidential records act that's what you
have to go by i guess
he's sure he didn't do anything wrong
and maybe it's because of something
related to the presidential records act
remember
this this really is a big deal for the
fbi and justice department to take this
step
you know
that they were really confident that
they knew exactly what they were looking
for they knew exactly what trump was
supposed to have turned over and that
they were crossing every eye and dotting
every t as sean hannity said
um
this this narrative just doesn't it's
not believable i mean that's what i'm
told and you sit you negotiate you try
working it out and if you don't i guess
there's a procedure if you can't work it
out yes and it's you know they're making
they're trying to make such a big deal
because what they want to do is
politicize everything yeah of course it
doesn't appear that that's the case it
appears as though the fbi gave donald
trump a lot of time to return the things
that he took and they had reason to
believe he hadn't returned it and they
were 100 correct um
lastly here is trump's still complaining
about the fbi being in his bedroom you
have that happen and then they do a raid
on the house of a former president who
was very popular i mean i did get
more votes than any sitting president in
history no committing president even
came close it's so it's almost like he's
saying
you can't raid a popular former
president you should only be able to
rate an unpopular one and they did a
raid on my house
and it's you know not the same you walk
in and you say these people were in here
and
in your bedroom and they were in
in bearings and melania's room
i mean when you think how terrible it is
it's terrible it's just absolutely
terrible and then absolute last clip
during this very same deranged and sick
interview trump's delusions about his
own power continue
he says if he were still the president
right now he would meet with putin and
he would get that invasion of ukraine
ended mr president it's rob finnerty i
don't think it can be overstated
inflation was 1.4 on your last day in
office gas was 239 a gallon uh quite a
difference 20 months later uh speaking
of russia vladimir putin wanted to
showcase russian strength in ukraine
when he invaded in february mr president
the opposite is happening that is clear
if you were in the oval office today how
would you do more to engage directly
with vladimir putin to try to get him to
stop this war
well i talked to him i'd meet with him i
mean there's no communication with him
with biden obviously there's not a lot
of
a lot of communication between biden and
these leaders these leaders are
pretty brutal and they're
people that you have to know how to deal
with and we dealt with them well with
china we took in hundreds of billions of
dollars of terrorism now remember that
china doesn't pay the tariffs american
companies do what's really funny about
that
is that when hillary clinton said this
really it it wasn't a great thing that
hillary said when hillary said
you know i went to wall street and i
told them cut it out
and everybody laughed at her because
it's so silly oh you told wall street to
cut it out i'm sure right away they're
going to cut it out trump's basically
saying the same thing here he's saying
listen i would have met with putin i
would have told him stop it
just stop it that's it uh it's pathetic
and increasingly trump's visibility is
coming on fringe networks like newsmax
not that fox news isn't fringe but it's
at least in terms of cable subscriptions
more mainstream but trump increasingly
relegated to more bizarre interviews on
smaller and smaller platforms all right
i i don't want to spend a lot of time on
this but i do want to show you just a
couple of other clips you know yesterday
i played a part of a very strange
interview where right-wing actor john
voight who seems pretty scrambled
himself i must say
john voigt was interviewing trump
and voight started weeping about how
good of a person donald trump is we now
have more clips from this truly bizarre
interview and in this clip during this
john voigt interview donald trump tosses
a word salad that i can't even describe
as a chop chop it's more of like a
confit just it's confetti is all it is
check this out it had to be
you know
approached and changed you took that on
and you made it into a great golf course
right and i think it's one of the most
donald trump's heroic golf course
restoration
is incredibly impressive to john voight
asthmatic golf courses in the country
now doral because of you so i have that
to thank you thank you mr president i'm
i'm just very grateful for your presence
in so many areas
but uh
first of all i think it's so nice the
way you expressed that and
even the slight little tears that come
you're just a fantastic person and i
really want people to come together
i want the united states to be one in
there by the way trump said he loves
that people cry over how great he is
that's what trump just said he loves the
tears that jon voight shed over how
great trump is understanding of the
greatness of this country and wanting
its future to be magnificent
for the new generations to come right
and and that means the world will go
toward peace
so i
i say to
the folks
i say let's
stay in hope
let's appreciate our country
and let's uh appreciate those who are
capable
of turning the tide and bringing us back
to
the greatness
that we were given by our founding
fathers
well i want to thank you and
we love the country the country's in
trouble
it's got to be solved
fairly quickly
there is no choice but to solve the
problem but it's a big problem it's a
big problem
and
i hope it continues forward and we love
israel and we hope everything's going to
be okay sure
a lot of good moves have to be made or
it's not going to be okay and
we
say god bless you and good luck john
thank you very much i appreciate it
thank you very much for this time mr
president
yeah
um what an unhinged and disjointed word
salad just attempting to throw bouquets
at each other but kind of failing
here's i played a short part of this
clip yesterday where john voigt cries
over how great trump is
here's a little bit of a longer a bit of
context on that and they tell a story
you went into the place and you uh you
checked on that place and whenever
somebody you come to anywhere everybody
says he knows everyone who works in
every one of his facilities now i know
you have
places all over the country
you went into the place and said is
sally so-and-so working here
today you went in and said yeah she's
have her come see me and you went to one
of the offices
and
she came in and you said i hear you're
having a little bit of it difficult
and she said well i have some cancer
issues
and
see i'm getting emotional see this is
from the
you keep saying the champ okay you can't
watch the champ without crying well i
can't
i can't
go through this story without crying
and you said i'll take care let me take
care of the uh
of the uh
whatever it's gonna cost
you know wanna take care of you you're
valuable to me whatever that is i mean
and that's who you are by the way
i know that voigt doesn't necessarily
mean it in a literal sense but you're
valuable to me
that's exactly the theme of how trump
sees his own supporters i've told you
all this before
trump cares about his supporters to the
extent that they're useful to him
even though really they're the folks
that he spent his entire rich life
trying to not be around
and this is all just so bonkers
i've tried to research this i was not
able to find any evidence that trump
paid for anyone's cancer treatment i saw
on video that trump made fun of a
disabled reporter that we all saw that
we know took place we saw the video
this story about trump paid for
someone's cancer treatment i was able to
find no proof of it okay
very quickly
trump's approval has plunged to its
lowest in a year
now i'm going to show you what the
number is and the number is actually
kind of scary
newsweek reports donald trump's approval
rating plunges to lowest point in over a
year this is based on an nbc news poll
54
negative approval rating and 34 positive
for trump
okay
trump had the same 54 negative in august
but a slightly higher positive of 36.
trump also had 36 positive in may and
march 37 in january okay doesn't matter
so there's two things going on here
number one
clearly to some degree
the country is reacting to the absurdity
of what this man has become it's a joke
complete and total joke and more and
more people have moved away from trump
that's a good thing
the scary thing is
how insane is this country
that more than a third of the country
still approves of trump
who has now been out of office for
20 months
who
has apparently done so many things that
go against the fundamentals of what this
country is based on both in spirit and
in practice when it comes to the law
humiliates us regularly and himself on
the world stage still as a former
president
and more than a third of the country
when ass says
i think i think trump's great i highly
approve of trump yeah he's fantastic
and there is a um
there's an excerpt from a book written
after world war ii
that describes how just ordinary germans
in nazi germany
descended into a state where there was
relatively high approval of hitler and
his uh nazi regime
and um you can google this it's uh
the university of chicago
has an excerpt from it the book is they
thought they were free the germans
1933-1945
the book is by milton mayer
and there's an excerpt called but then
it was too late and it talks about the
slow descent into
yeah i mean i guess i do approve even
though if you if we now went back six
years and described what trump is now
you wouldn't say would you approve of
that you wouldn't get 34 or 36 percent
approval you wouldn't but there's this
slow descent slow descent into madness
one other piece
i think
is a good idea to read if you want to
understand what's going on is by alex
shepherd in new republic it's called
donald trump is more deranged than ever
as his approval ratings sink the
president is more and more unhinged and
more willing to indulge his most
dangerous followers and that's very
relevant to you know we saw this q anon
moment during trump's ohio rally over
the weekend also extraordinarily
dangerous that article which we will
link to instructive and informative and
very very scary let's take a quick break
we're going to be right back after this
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpacman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
it is great to have back on the program
benjamin dixon host of the benjamin
dixon morning show who is uh up to some
very important work i will say which
we're going to talk about ben always
great having you on david it's a
pleasure thanks so much for having me so
christian nationalism you know sometimes
there's this shorthand when when people
say well what what does christian
nationalism mean and you can imagine a
spectrum where on one side you have
separation of church and state where
whatever one's religion is it has
nothing to do with civil government
the shorthand that sometimes is used is
will the opposite side of that spectrum
is for example marjorie taylor green who
says no
her christianity should be exactly what
dictates and determines how civil
government should operate is that the
right way to think about this movement
absolutely i think marjorie taylor
greene inadvertently gave us the perfect
lens to which we need to understand this
threat that's coming from i would like
to say my colleagues uh in the christian
faith but there is a sect of christians
who believe that their specific brand of
christianity should be what dominates
the entirety of society and clearly
that's a threat not only to those who
choose not to believe or have any other
belief but it's a threat to those of us
christians who simply do not believe in
the sectarianism and the tribalism of
christian nationalism
has something materially changed since
like i remember in the early days of my
show
there would be
the televangelists and you would see a
little bit of an inkling of this
christian nationalism but you didn't see
as much over you know you can't be
christian and vote for a democrat
uh preaching politics from the pulpit
was it there but less overt or has
something actually changed
there's it well it certainly has been
there the entire time there's always
been a faction of the christian uh
religion that believes in dominionism
and
dominionism is quite literally the best
way to describe it they believe that
they have the authority to dominate
society some of them even go as far as
believing that they should bring do what
they can to
expedite the apocalypse so to speak that
trend has always been there but what
kind of control they had inside of the
republican party um that was a different
question and we saw back when i got
started even i got started around the
jeremiah right time there was this
belief in the republican party that they
could capitalize on the evangelical vote
without having to subscribe or bow down
to the more zealotrous form of evangelic
white evangelicalism to be specific and
we see now that after years and years
and years of getting the votes of these
particular types of evangelicals that
group has taken control of the
republican party can you mention white
evangelicals can you talk a little bit
about the the kind of racial breakdown
of these movements because we've known
for a while that
uh for example in the prop 8 era in
california there certainly are
conservative religious values in black
churches that's right but
is there a difference in terms of the
political application as it comes to
christian nationalism between some of
these different groups of churches
absolutely i think back i harkened back
to the statement from malcolm x that 11
o'clock on sunday mornings is the most
segregated time
in america and that's because there's a
fundamental difference between
black christianity and white
evangelicalism not so much in terms of
our belief in jesus that fundamental
belief in jesus is the same but you have
to take into context when black people
were praying for deliverance from jim
crow praying for deliverance from
slavery we were literally asking god to
deliver us from white evangelicals who
would lynch us on sunday morning and
then go to sunday school so the
difference really lies in the value of
human life in terms of black people
the willingness to
um decapitate the entire message of
justice you think about the thomas
jefferson bible uh where they completely
erased any semblance of justice and the
narratives of setting free the captive
they took that out of the bible and gave
that to the slave the enslaved person
because they under fundamentally
understood that that messaging would
galvanize a black liberation movement
which inevitably happened anyway
you know i got a call i think it was
last week or the week before from a
self-described white progressive
christian and this guy
described his views about a number of
different issues
and they were pretty conservative views
but what made him a progressive was he
doesn't think any of those opinions
should have any bearing on what
government does so that's an interesting
thing because sometimes it's not about i
mean i don't know you you tell me when
we talk about the progressive christian
movement is it still conservative but it
says that that conservatism should be
completely separate from how folks vote
or what is it exactly yeah there's a
wide range of beliefs in christianity i
mean in terms of like so if we just talk
about social issues there's a large
group of christians who
fundamentally and they use theology to
support lgbtq rights so there is a broad
range but even in the progressive
circles that hold on to conservative
beliefs like you mentioned the black
community is extremely conservative on a
lot of issues but where they draw we
draw the line fundamentally is we don't
believe that our beliefs should be used
to discriminate against anyone else
whereas marjory taylor green not only
believes that those beliefs should be
used to discriminate they believe that
it should be the fundamental tool by
which we organize society they don't
believe in democracy anymore they
fundamentally believe in a theocratic
fascist state and when we talk about the
particular theology it is a white
supremacist christian nationalist
theology
hey when it comes to like the future of
the of christianity in the context of
christian nationalism i think i've seen
you either say or i read in some of the
info you sent me that you see
christian nationalism as a threat to
christians and christianity as as you
describe yourself as a part of that
movement can you explain that no
absolutely uh in the clip that's going
viral now there's a uh there's a
particular white evangelical pastor who
was disgusted with the fact that black
people call ourselves christian
and the reason for that disgust is
because he hated the fact that we fight
for
justice we fight for liberation we fight
for democracy we fight for things that
he feels is anathema to his particular
belief so there is a clear divide in not
only a divide but
we are not safe you have to understand
and anyone i mean i'm sure everyone can
contextualize it for history like this
type of nationalism this type of
christian nationalism was the
justification for slavery it's now being
used as a justification for the bigotry
that we're seeing on every front so i
don't think black christians are safe at
all i think we are going to be targeted
just as much as let's say the lgbtqia
community it's been interesting i guess
interesting i don't know there's
probably a different term for it but
it's been notable that
christian nationalism has grown arguably
as much as at any time in the last
couple of decades during the presidency
of a guy who clearly was lying about his
religiosity like it's very very obvious
that trump was never religious trump was
never against abortion he kind of
contrived all these things in the run-up
to being the republican nominee because
democrats weren't going to going to make
him the the nominee
do you know what
i mean i don't even know how to ask the
question like what do you make of that
because you would think
that you would not necessarily
see the growth of this movement when the
while they are simultaneously
you know uh pledging loyalty to a guy
who is obviously not religious yeah it's
a it's a really uh acute case of special
pleading
they are willing to ignore everything
about donald trump because they felt
like he was the vessel that could
accomplish their agenda and in so many
ways he has right with all the
conservative appointments uh to the
supreme court and through the entire
judiciary now with the throwback of roe
versus wade he has been a vessel to
accomplish their ends they did not care
whether or not he was more like satan or
jesus that was completely immaterial to
them um and and i think we saw that
happen in that election and it's also
the last thing i'll say about it is that
these christian nationalists you will
notice that they don't use the language
of jesus they use the language of
traditional values and they get to
define those traditional values so i
would argue that it's not only the
result of them wanting to use donald
trump i believe they have the same level
of faith as donald trump they're they're
in the realm of heresy based on their
own bible they are looking at donald
trump as the second coming of christ
there's a book out now that literally
calls trump the second coming of christ
i saw that it's a political opportunism
and they want power just as much as
anything else they want political power
and economic power when folks talk about
how to fight against this movement one
of the first things that's mentioned is
hey you know
if you're doing any kind of politics as
a church you should lose your tax-exempt
status and there's this feeling among
some that the best way to fight this is
essentially a financial fight demand
investigations into the non-profit
status of some of these churches and get
them maybe i guess to lose that status
even though it very rarely happens
there's some hope that if the irs does
uh kind of scale up operations a little
bit maybe this is something that they
would look at although it doesn't really
seem like a priority do you think that
that's an important and viable way of
fighting this or do you think there are
other better ways well actually i don't
think it is not because i i disagree
with the tactic i i do agree that if you
are going to use tax-exempt dollars to
accomplish political ends you should
lose your 501 c 3 status that's what the
law says sure however there's nothing
that you can give a christian more than
a victim narrative if you can give them
a narrative vote we're under attack by
the irs their donations are going to go
up so i don't think it's an effective
strategy i think the more effective
strategy is to really
extrapolate a little bit higher because
despite what any christian believes in
their individual dogma if they are
if if they consider themselves to be a
person of good faith then they
understand that we're going to have to
coexist and i know that word has gotten
a little kind of uh kumbayash but the
fact of the matter is is that there is a
an alliance that has to be made between
people of good faith whatever they
believe so the irs technique is
pro i don't know if they want to go
after that that's fine i think that
gives uh christians nationalists more
tools to complain about
so
what are some of the other ways that
individuals whether they are or aren't
religious can get involved in pushing
back against this well one you could
just call them out on their own frame
right um if i think a lot of times some
of my friends and the atheists or
agnostic community they they want they
would rather
challenge the frame and dismiss the
possibility of god my suggestion is call
them out on their own bs right there's
nothing about christian nationalism
that's remotely like jesus based on the
bible right there's nothing it's like
gandhi said though he was a bit of a
racist he had this right he said that i
like your christ just not your
christians and there's no part of what
is being pushed by the christian
nationalists that's even remotely kind
or just or reflects the image of christ
and even if they don't like the image of
christ i'm not talking about our allies
in the atheist community they're just
not good people
i i think we can attack them on their
own frame because they can't even stand
up to their own their own test
last thing i want to talk about we saw
the supreme court overturn roe v wade it
was very obvious when that happened like
after your biggest victory you don't
stop so so you know you're gonna keep
going now lindsey graham has proposed an
outright federal ban on abortion we
don't know if gay marriage might be
coming next you know very far down
there's this idea of interracial
marriage although i don't think it's a
priority oh ben did i just lose you oh
we might have lost ben
let's see if we can get ben back
oh no
let's see if we can get ben back what
what did we were getting right to the
crescendo of the interview let's see if
we can get him back here
oh my
would be really a shame if i wasn't able
to get this question
hmm
something must have happened to his
internet tubes
oh boy
well listen we were coming to the end of
our time my question to ben was going to
be
um
do you expect
to see the churches
the right-wing churches get even more
extreme
now that they sort of won in a way on
overturning roe v wade are they just
going to be pushing for more and more
extreme things but we'll have to save it
for next time
benjamin dixon has been joining us until
we lost him
host of the benjamin dixon morning show
we will link to all of his stuff he's
doing great work fighting christian
nationalism and we will take a quick
break and be back right after this
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon
go to patreon.com david pakman show
where you can get access to behind the
scenes videos the daily bonus show the
commercial free daily show as well as
special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show i want to give you a little
sort of chapter in the book about how
extreme the american right-wing movement
is getting there's this uh sort of like
on-campus right-wing group called
turning point usa charlie kirk is one of
the
um sort of more uh publicly uh known
people associated with this group
turning point usa
they have now jumped fully into this
sort of conspiracy q anon alex jones
fray to the point that at a recent event
called defeating the great reset the
great reset is a favorite
idea i guess we would call it of people
like alex jones and steve bannon and
those types charlie kirk actually
interviewed alex jones this was at one
point sort of like cons i i never
considered them this but considered by
the right a very mainstream right-wing
group just indoctrinating college
students into basic conservative
economics and this type of thing
it is
completely over the hill
insane at this point in time and i'm
going to play for you a clip here of
charlie kirk making a really big deal of
i mean listen after all it's just alex
jones it's just a conspiracy theorist
this is the great thinker that turning
point usa
is bringing to its attendees it's it's
sad but also scary in that it shows how
extreme this movement has gotten a
special remote guest for you now
i only ask this since we're doing the
remote guest um while i'm while we're
talking i just want to make sure our
guest can hear
everything we're saying and all that so
i was told by everybody
it's not the president trump but it is
gonna make you guys wait till you see
this all right wow
must be pretty good in fact this man is
more hated by the media than donald
trump and that says something okay
which is so
if you're gonna talk about the great
reset right then you have to have which
by the way i don't know why you would
but someone who's the most banned man in
america alex jones joins us
[Applause]
how exciting uh we're now gonna get the
truth
[Music]
standing ovation to the guy who said
something about
gay frogs and that sandy hook was fake
[Applause]
so alex whoa alex welcome remotely i was
told by all the people like oh you can't
have alex at your event which makes me
just want to have alex even more
anything that people say is bad is
actually good that's fundamentally
conservatism sometimes
and i want to be reactionary
conservatism
sometimes things that people say are bad
are actually just bad
alex you wrote a book on the great reset
what's the great reset why did you write
the
book well i saw c banner yesterday and
he's absolutely right and i love the you
know the title yeah um they are now
including alex jones in official
turning point usa events
here's what i hope you will glean from
this
these are considered the thinkers among
the right
these are considered the thinkers among
the right here's one more clip where
alex jones talks about cows biblically
let's let's zero in on the food thing
alex in particular they are fascinated
with getting rid of meat
talk more about that but also talk about
the other implications of getting rid of
meat testosterone levels maybe replacing
with this synthetic nonsense that bill
gates just happens to also be an
investor in by the way super crony
capitalist talk about the why they're so
incredibly focused on eradicating meat
from our planet what's going what's
going on with us yeah tell us well if
you go back to genesis anybody should go
read it written three thousand plus
years ago by amazing jewish scribes
i'm so not anti-semitic that i'm gonna
call the jewish scribes amazing inspired
by god
i mean in the first chapter they just
keep talking about cows and meat all day
long and saying that's the real symbol
of freedom now moses said later we're
not going to worship the golden cats
that's idolatry but they were worshiping
golden cow let's let's this this guy is
truly pathetic and i want to tell you
what the real scam is here
the real scam
is this entire movement pretending to
care about the bible we talked with ben
dixon about this in the last segment and
he says these people aren't even really
christian
um
this was the moment
at which point it became clear
that the five six years that followed
were going to be republicans
pretending to care about the bible you
mentioned the bible you've been talking
about how it's your favorite book and
you said i think last night in iowa some
people are surprised that you say that
i'm wondering what one or two of your
most favorite bible uh verses are i
wouldn't want to get into it because to
me that's very personal you know when i
talk about the bible it's very personal
so i don't want to get into girls i
don't want to get into it
by the way
notice how articulate trump was even
just how much more articulate trump was
even just a few years ago a lot to you
that you think about her
the bible means a lot to me but i don't
want to get into specifics
even decide a verse
i don't want to do that an old testament
guy or a new testament probably
equal i think it's just an incredible
are you a pancakes or a french toast guy
both are good both are really good
the whole bible is an incredible i joke
very much so they always hold up the art
of the deal i say my second favorite
book of all time but uh i just think the
bible is just something very special
it's super special and donald trump is
not going to say any any more about it
these are the exact type of panderers
that ben dixon was just warning about in
the last segment
who he is fighting against really scary
stuff
all right this is this is sad news
our good friend
who has filled in for me before
uh jesse dollamore
announced yesterday
that he sadly has cancer
and he has a whole video message about
it to his audience
and he explains that he went in for and
this is there's a twitter thread that
you can look at
um he went in for a colonoscopy late
last week
and yesterday he was told that he has
colon cancer
and there's a mass
and it is
adenocarcinoma
does not yet know the stage or the
prognosis but believes that it's not
stage four meaning it hasn't spread to
other organs
jesse's going to need surgery
he is going to then learn is it stage
one or two in which case that's
hopefully the end of the journey or as
he writes if it's three then he would
start chemo
there's a lot of uncertainty
and um we are
all pulling for jesse as uh as i tweeted
to him yesterday i was just on a call
with jesse
because we were
working on some stuff and jesse has
super graciously
filled in for me in the past last summer
and he's just a really nice guy the the
thing about jesse is that
um
the nice guy that you see in his clips
is really jesse
and um
it's horrible news and i know that lots
of our other friends in the
uh progressive media community are
rallying around jesse there's no ask
here right now i'm just telling you all
about something in the community that's
going on that's that's horrible
so um feel free to
send jesse a tweet we're of course
wishing him the best or you know you can
leave positive vibes over on the video
clip that he did about this or really
just whatever
but we send jesse our best
really sad news
and we hope to have good news from jesse
about
treatment and prognosis
sooner than later all right jesse
everybody here is pulling for you
if you have something you want to say to
me and there's never an easy transition
out of uh out of a cancer diagnosis if
you have something you want to say to me
you can leave a voicemail at 219 to
david p
um the eggman actually called in we
could use a little levity the eggman
called in
and you know we did this story yesterday
about how mike pillow
says he's suing the fbi he's suing
everyone and of course we all know how
silly these lawsuits are
eggman says you know think about it if
you're pillow's lawyer
or lawyers and you know he's got 300
million dollars you'll sue whoever the
hell he wants you to sue take the money
and run this is the egg man's
perspective on that
hey dave imagine your pillow's lawyer
one of his lawyers you're at this
meeting at hardee's or arby's wherever
they go and he says maybe kfc the fbi
and we're gonna sue the president and
the lawyers are like how do we take this
man's money he has 30 million dollar
billion dollars worth of money but still
not do the ridiculous things he wants
how do we placate this man his lawyers
are telling him sure we'll sue the fbi
for you mike write the check write the
check so his lawyers are getting loaded
probably laughing their asses off at his
insane request it may be god imagine the
waitress in that meeting is probably
smarter than all of them put together
shalom yes shalom of course and uh very
very soon we will be at rosh hashanah
eggman
eggman uh steve eggman no the eggman
um
yeah i think uh eggman may be on to
something with trump it's sort of the
opposite
with trump
lawyers don't want to represent him
because he'll often just never pay them
with pillow assuming pillow pays
lawyers will probably be willing to do
whatever pillow wants sue the fbi sure
sue the secret service sue the cia yeah
why not let's sue everybody uh if they
can actually rack up money from pillow
uh eggman may well be on to something on
today's bonus show we are going to talk
about the first in the nation law
protecting children's online privacy the
law is out of california we will
describe it
and we will discuss it for those of you
who
listen to the first season of the serial
podcast
adnan syed
has been released from prison and what
that means if you did not listen to
cereal the first season you would know
but i'll be look i will explain all of
it on today's bonus show i think it'll
be a really interesting conversation and
we are also going to talk about the
illinois plan to end cash bail
and the uh and the criminalization of
poverty it is not a perfect law
it's not
but we don't want to let the perfect
become the enemy of the good to quote
the great ted kennedy
uh and we will discuss that on today's
bonus show you can sign up at
joinpakman.com
if you missed yesterday's one day
membership special and you would like to
take advantage just email in info
davidpakman.com ask for the coupon code
and it shall be sent to you so you can
take advantage of it we will see
everybody on the bonus show in a moment
or otherwise back here on the podcast
tomorrow
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors i protect all of
my passwords accounts and devices using
aura i get instant alerts about threats
like if my email or password or found on
the dark web so i can fix the problem
fast try aura free for two weeks using
my link below